[Music]
only 21 of you are subscribed subscribe
to support the channel and future
content hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing harry potter the prisoner of
azkaban dementors and tom riddle more
specifically we're going to be
discussing a recurring event in the
prison of azkaban harry's encounters
with dementors and the shocking truth
behind what harry hears during these
attacks
i'm also going to be discussing a theory
for why dementors seem to be so drawn to
harry are his numerous run-ins with
dementors the result of sheer dumb
misfortune or were they drawn to him for
another more sinister reason
dementors are of course the prison
guards of azkaban giant dark cloak
creatures three meters tall with dark
gray scabby skin and if they don't sound
awful enough already it turns out
they're also representative of
depression dementors are among the
foulest creatures that walk this earth
they infest the darkest filthiest places
they glory and decay and despair they
drain peace hope and happiness out of
the air around them even muggles feel
their presence though they can't see
them get too near a dementor and every
good feeling every happy memory will be
sucked out of you if it can the dementor
will feed on you long enough to reduce
you to something like itself
soulless and evil you'll be left with
nothing but the worst experiences of
your life one of the recurring moments
throughout the third book movie is the
appearance of dementors and a
particularly chilling effect they have
on harry potter himself
every time harry is confronted with a
dementor he hears the screams of his
mother as she is murdered by lord
voldemort this first occurs right in the
beginning of the prisoner of azkaban an
intense cold swept over them all harry
felt his own breath catch in his chest
the cold went deeper than his skin it
was inside his chest it was inside his
very heart harry's eyes rolled up into
his head he couldn't see he was drowning
in cold there was a rushing in his ears
as though of water he was being dragged
downward the roaring growing louder and
then from far away he heard screaming
terrible terrified pleading screams he
wanted to help whoever it was he tried
to move his arms but couldn't a thick
white fog was swirling around him inside
him harry recalls one of his attacks
when they get near me i can hear
voldemort murdering my mum
now let me start off by saying that it's
pretty much the general consensus that
the scream harry hears while on the
train back to hogwarts and the prisoner
of azkaban belongs to his mother lily
why is she screaming well she's
screaming because voldemort is in her
family's home and she is pleading with
him to spare harry's life to take her
instead the reason for this assumption
is because when one encounters a
dementor they're forced to relive and
they felt during the worst memory of
their lives logically in harry's case
this would be the murder of his mother
which he was conscious for albeit a baby
but what i want to do today is challenge
this notion and this quote from harry
battling a dementor fighting for his
soul is certainly no pleasant or easy
experience to deal with which is why i
think that harry may have things upside
down
in the disorientating experience that is
a dementor attack i'm of the impression
that what harry heard wasn't actually
his memory at all but rather voldemort's
let me explain it all started the night
of the attack on the potter cottage
wednesday october 31st it was on this
day that voldemort traveled to the town
of godric's hollow where the potter
family lived it was here that voldemort
in an attempt to murder harry ended up
murdering james and lily he had a very
specific goal and that was to kill harry
after disposing of his parents the time
finally came for voldemort to end harry
letting out one last of ardikadavra
voldemort had full intention of killing
harry as without his death there was no
way of ensuring that the prophecy
wouldn't come true or so he thought at
last he points his wand at harry
unleashing the killing curse upon the
small child however the curse was
stopped in his tracks for you see a
loving sacrifice that lily had put in
place ensured that harry was protected
this meant that voldemort's killing
curse came firing right back at him what
voldemort essentially did on this day
was turn harry into a horcrux you see
when voldemort tried to kill harry the
curse rebounded which split voldemort's
soul but because voldemort's body was
gone the victim of his own curse he
could no longer encase the soul fragment
to complete the horcrux creation part of
horcrux creation involves an encasing
spell which actually puts the soul
outside of the body into a physical
object because voldemort's soul was left
without any attachment it latched itself
to harry for this reason harry contained
voldemort's soul fragment but was never
possessed by it what this did do however
was form a close connection between the
two of them a piece of his soul now
existed within harry which meant that
the pair shared some thoughts and
abilities harry's ability to speak
parcel tongue for example came from this
bond on a higher level though their
lives were now tied to one another so
what does this mean for harry's
experience on the train well it meant
that harry was living out voldemort's
worst memory of course the pair had a
psychic connection and it's reinforced
again and again throughout the story
that in a lot of ways their minds are
interconnected on this kind of level
after the attack on the train harry's
considerably drained and it's emphasized
throughout the story that he's extra
sensitive to dementors so why would that
be well it's because every time he's
attacked he gets to live out the worst
memories of two individuals his and
voldemort's when harry his screaming on
the train it's from two perspectives his
own and voldemort's it makes perfect
sense that the two would share a worst
memory as well harry's worst memory
being the murder of his mother and
voldemort's worst memory being the night
he was bested unable to kill the boy who
lived as if her first hand experience of
your mother dying wasn't enough harry
got to relive it every time he was
attacked by dementors not only that but
he also got to experience all of the
anguish and pain associated with
voldemort's worst memory all at the same
time in essence harry is twice as
sensitive to dementors okay so that
answers the questions of what harry
really heard as well as why harry is so
sensitive to the dementor's kiss
however it doesn't answer why they're so
attracted to him constantly putting
himself in harm's way aside they seem to
always be going after him the dementor's
primary form of attack the dementor's
kiss is effectively a means of sucking
out that person's soul a fate worse than
death so if their main motivation is to
suck out more souls then why should they
be particularly drawn to harry remus
lupin seemed to always express that it
was the horrors of harry's past that
drew them closer to him but i don't
agree with that i've got a different
theory like i mentioned earlier when
voldemort traveled to godric's hollow he
inadvertently made harry a living
horcrux placing a piece of his own soul
inside of him this meant that harry not
only carried one soul with him but a
piece of someone else's as well bearing
this in mind my theory is this the
dementors were attracted to the extra
soul that harry carried with him harry
went about his life in business with an
extra soul strapped to him and i think
this made him a target to dementors a
sort of two for the price of one to a
dementor harry was the ultimate treat
what do you guys think of these theories
leave a comment down below if you enjoy
the content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
so
[Music]
you